>> From the library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>>Aimee Picard Soller:
Our author today,
Chris Bohjalian describes
himself in a social media bio
as author, bicyclist, and gym rat.
He is those things I'm sure,
as well as New York Times
best-selling author of 19 books.
His novel, Midwives, was a number
one New York Times best seller,
a selection of Oprah's book club,
a publishers weekly best book,
and a New England Booksellers
Association discovery pick.
His work has been translated
into over 30 languages
and three motion pictures.
And, a fourth is in the works
with the Sandcastle Girls being
adapted from a feature film.
He's written for many
publications including the Times,
the Washington Post,
Cosmopolitan, and Readers Digest.
He is currently a fellow
of the Vermont academy
of arts and sciences.
And his latest novel,
"The Sleepwalkers" was
released in January.
And, readers can anxiously
anticipate his next novel,
The Flight Attendant, in March.
Chris's awards include the
Armenian National Committee
of American Freedom Award for
his work in educating Americans
about the Armenian genocide.
The Armenian National Committee
of America Arts and Letters Award
for the Sandcastle Girls.
The New England Society Book
Award for the Night Strangers.
The New England Book Award.
Russia's Concord Award
for the Sandcastle Girls.
A Boston public library
literary light.
A finalist for the Lamda Literary
Awards for Trans Sister Radio.
A best lifestyle column
for Idyll Banter,
and the Vermont Press Association.
Fans of his work marvel at his
ability to develop a character
with such depth and
article language.
He says that he allows
the characters to develop
and lead him through the stories.
His books are always
edited using a fountain pen
as he says they are messy and
they force you to think slowly.
Chris has said that he
found his voice in Vermont
where he lives with
his wife Victoria.
That is there he was able to
develop the novels and characters
that readers have come
to know and love.
We are very glad that he's
brought his voice here to DC
in the national book festival today.
Please note that after
Chris's remarks he will be
in the book signing section
from 1 to 2 p.m. Please join me
in welcoming Chris to
the festival stage.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris Bohjalian: Thank you,
Amy, for that introduction.
It is a pleasure, it is an
honor, it is a privilege to be
at the national book festival.
Today -- I spoke yesterday at the
Library of Congress which is one
of the great honors any
author can ever experience.
I thank all of you for celebrating
with me today with words and reading
and books can mean to the soul.
It's a particular pleasure to be
with all of you this afternoon
because I'm not on a book tour.
Make no mistake.
I like book tours.
It wasn't all that long ago
that my book sold briskly
but only among people
with my last name.
I try never to lose sight of that.
Most people presume, however,
that book tours are
unbelievably glamorous.
You jet around the country and
you hang with Oprah and Katie
and Terry Gross and sell
whole pallets of books.
But, the reality of
most book tours is this.
They have moments that
are far more humbling
than our honorific this afternoon.
I will share with you but one.
I am in Memphis, Tennessee.
I get to the airport at five
in the morning because I am
on a 6 a.m. flight to
Jackson, Mississippi.
When I get there everything on
the concourse is closed except
for one guy with a cart selling
something he calls a gritty cat.
A bear claw pastry that has
been deep fried in grits.
I'm thinking to myself I'm going
to have one of those bad boys.
I'm just about to get on
a turbo prop, why not.
So, I had my gritty cat.
It's not bad.
Get on the plane.
It's a 17-seater and there
are three other passengers,
and it's a really choppy rainy day.
And, so, the pilot says we're going
to be on the tarmac for a little bit
and it's going to be a choppy
ride, no cabin service.
We take off and it is choppy.
We've been in the air no
more than, I don't know,
three and a half minutes when the
woman two rows behind me vomits.
So, I'm thinking to myself
I'm a frequent flier but just
in case let's get the
air sickness bag.
So, I reach into in seat pocket
to get the air sickness bag
and there's not one there.
At which point the gentleman
a few rows ahead of me vomits.
So, I'm thinking to myself
these are more desperate times
than you realize.
So, I unbuckle, stand up
planning to go seat to seat
to find an air sickness bag.
So, I stand up unbuckled
and the flight attendant
says to me sir, sit down.
Sit down now.
And, in a post 911 era when a
flight attendant says sit down,
sit down now, you do, and I did.
And, at that point, the third other
passenger vomited leaving me the
last passenger standing.
So, we do level out, and we are
circling for a really long time
over Jackson because
the air is so choppy,
and I'm concreasingly
worried about this chop
and whether I'm going to make it.
But, finally, the pilot says
we're about to begin our descent.
And I'm thinking you're good, but we
hit a bump, and it was pretty scary.
So, I reach into the
seat pocket ahead of me,
take out the in flight magazine,
rip out two thick glossy pages,
swirl them into a snow
cone, fold the bottom.
And, I don't know whether it is
a thousand feet above Jackson
or 2,000 feet above Jackson,
but you're looking at the guy
who created the first ever
airborne snow cone of vomit.
So, we land.
And, the flight attendants
very grateful
that I don't give him my
airborne snow cone of vomit.
I go to the men's room.
I clean myself up.
And, then I go to baggage.
Whenever you are on a book tour
your publisher gives you an escort.
Not that kind.
These are the lovely woman and men
who know where all of the libraries
and the book stores are and they
get you to and from the airport
and you find them in baggage because
they are holding up your book.
So, I go into baggage and I
see a woman holding a book.
Not my book, and I'm thinking
wow, that's a cookbook.
One of the people on the
plane with you was a chef.
But, then she says Chris.
And, I said yes.
And, she says hi -- and
she introduces herself --
and she says I forgot your book
at home but I found this cookbook
in the back seat of the car and
figured it would do just fine.
And then she says I
got some bad news.
You circled so long that
you missed your slot
on the public radio station.
And, I said that's okay.
And, then she says
you must be hungry.
And, as a matter of fact, I was.
And, so she said I'm going to bring
you to the best waffles in Jackson.
And, I get in the car with her.
And, we drive and we
drive, and all of a sudden,
we are in the country
nowhere near a restaurant.
And, I realized I am living
out Steven King's misery.
I am never going to see my
wife and daughter again.
And, in the middle of
nowhere, we pull into a house.
And, in all fairness,
it's a really nice house.
We're talking serious medomansion.
But, she gets out of
the car, and I'm sitting
in the passenger seat
thinking do you text in 911.
And, she says in her best Sandra
Bullock The Blindside voice well,
are you coming.
And, I realized I was a coming.
So, I got out of the
car, I follow her
into the garage and there's a door.
And, I know that behind that door
is either a kitchen or a dungeon.
We open the door and
yes, it's a kitchen.
And, in there are four
guys in golf clothes.
Two massive William snow
[inaudible] waffle makers.
She's brought me to her house where
her husband, her brother in law,
and their two best friends from
Minnesota get together every week
in October for golf and waffles.
She welcomes me into
this wonderful man cave.
And, her husband says
to me with a red bull
and a green bull what would
you like on your waffles.
We got ourselves pulled
pork and Cajun shrimp.
And, I said I'm a blueberry
waffle man myself.
And, his wife says George, I
told you, he's a vegetarian.
At which point George -- and I'm
not making up one word of this --
says I'm going to make
you something special.
He gets on a stool, reaches up
into the top shelf of the pantry,
gets down a bag of grits and says
you ever had yourself a gritty
cat waffle.
I actually categorized this
among the unhorrific moments
because it was a really
lovely morning and the way
that this woman welcomed
me into her home
and her family it was
a great, great day.
It's a particular pleasure to be at
this book festival because it is all
about libraries and the
Library of Congress.
I am a novelist for lot of reasons.
But, a big one are libraries.
And, very specifically the
Hialeah Miami Lakes public library
in south Florida.
When I was in eighth grade,
my family moved from a suburb
of New York City to Miami, Florida,
which is arguably another
suburb of New York City.
And, we moved there the
Friday of Labor Day weekend.
That Tuesday, I started school
at Palm Springs Junior High.
And, then I went to see
my new orthodontist.
A sagest it would turn
out if there ever was one.
He gave me some orthodontic
headgear that looked
like the business end of a back ho.
Think Bane from the movie
Batman, the Dark Knight.
And, I had to wear this
device for four hours a day.
I wasn't allowed to sleep
when I was wearing it,
I couldn't speak when
I was wearing it.
So, I would come home from
Palm Springs Junior High.
I would put in my headgear
and I would go
to the Hialeah Miami Lakes
public library and I would read.
And, I would read so
many of the books
that an eighth grader was likely
to read in the late 1970's.
Steven King had started publishing
his remarkable grand [inaudible].
I read William Peter
Blatty's, The Exorcist.
Peter Benchley's deceptively
wonderful and really appropriate
if you live in south
Florida novel, Jaws.
And, I read a higher caliber
of literature as well.
It was at that library
for the first time
that I read Harper Lee's
To Kill a Mockingbird.
And, Joyce Carol Oates national book
award winning The Expensive People.
I still recall the first
sentences of Expensive People.
Five words.
I was a child murderer.
The next three pages deconstruct
that one short sentence.
Is the narrator an adult
who one time is a child
accidently kill someone.
Or, something far darker,
an adult serial killer
who on a regular basis
murder small children.
I was a child murderer.
From those books, I learned so much
that would help me
as an adult writer.
From the Blatty and the Benchly,
I first learned the importance
of linear momentum
and narrative drive.
What is it in a book that
keeps us turning the pages
into the small hours of the morning.
From Harper Lee and Joyce Carol
Oates I first began to realize
that the narrator in a first-person
novel is a fictional construct too.
And, every bit is made up
is the fictional characters
around him or her.
Now, you would think after
an epiphany like that
in eighth grade I would be
killing it as a young writer.
Nope. You're looking
at a guy who managed
to amass 250 rejection slips
before I sold a single word.
When you graduate from college,
Penguin Random House doesn't say
to you you look like a
young writer, promise.
Here's a boat load of
money, go write us a book.
So, you get a day job.
And, I was working in
New York City at an adage
and see my work was
working as a bond trader
on the 104th floor of 2 World Trade.
And, every day between
five and 7 a.m.
in the morning I would
write fiction.
I would write very F Scott
Fitzgerald short stories
and send them relentlessly to
the New Yorkers and Harpers
and the Suwanee review and be
summarily and consistently rejected.
And, I remember when I got
rejection number 250 thinking
to myself plan A not working.
Time to try plan B. And, at the time
Cosmopolitan was publishing a lot
of fiction.
So, I rounded up six months'
worth of Cosmopolitans
and I read them thoroughly
really trying
to understand what constitutes
a Cosmopolitan short story.
And, then I wrote one.
It's about a female super model
who lives in lower Manhattan
and is married to a fabulously
wealthy arbitrage trader
but their marriage is kind of dicey.
So, one weekend she goes out to
their equally cool beach house
on Fire Island, the Atlantic Ocean,
to see if their marriage
can be saved but instead,
spends the entire time playing
scantily clad beach volley ball.
Cosmopolitan bought it.
First story I ever sold.
And for the archivists among us,
I need to tell you that it is
in a very special issue
of Cosmopolitan.
The only issue of Cosmopolitan,
a magazine that is known for sex,
that ever had nudity in it.
I am in the yes, infamous now build
your better bust breast issue.
My mother was so proud.
After that story was published,
much to my utter astonishment,
literary agents began
to approach me.
And they all asked the same
thing, have you written a novel.
And, I haven't which was ironic
because in college
I'd never been one
of those young writers
desperately trying
to understand the [inaudible]
natural magic of Lori Moore,
Andre Debus, Raymond Carver, the
masters of the modern short story.
I'd always love the
door stops, [inaudible],
the 40 days of Musa Dagh.
Anna Karenina.
But, urged on by these agents, I
gave up the immediate gratification
of writing the short story to
hunker down and write a novel.
And, a year later, I had one.
And, much to my other astonishment,
an agent sold it instantly.
Now, in all fairness
this was the late 1980's
when grocery lists
could be sold as novels.
But, it was a novel and it
was going to be published.
My wife and I moved from our 520
square foot apartment in Brooklyn
to an 1898 Victorian in
Vermont, and I continued to work
at ad agencies here so, you know,
we'd have a health plan
and mortgage money.
And, the novel was published.
But, now we're living in Vermont.
And, you are looking at
the author responsible
for the single worst first
novel ever published bar none.
How bad is that first book.
On a Sunday afternoon in
Vermont, my wife gets a phone call
from her college roommate who
lives in Cambridge, Massachusetts
and says oh, my gosh, Chris's book,
it's reviewed in the
Boston Globe today.
This is my first major review
so my wife says oh, my gosh,
that's wonderful, is it good?
And, her roommate realizing she has
made an egregious mistake calling
says I don't remember.
So, my wife says can
you read it to us.
And, her roommate thinking
infinitely more quickly now says I
would but I've already bound
the newspapers up for recycling
and they're in the
basement of the apartment.
This was 1989.
Years before you could
go www.dotbostonglobe.com
and assess the carnage.
So, I had to wait until the next day
to go to the Fletcher free library
in Burlington Vermont to read
the day before's Boston Globe
and a review of my first novel
that ends with this paragraph.
And, so, although Bohjalin attacks
his first novel with real energy,
his writing is stylus
and without grace.
And, the quaint Saint Martin's
tradition of citing the editors
in the acknowledgements in this
case did absolutely nothing
to insure the quality of
editorial detail a subpar debut
in every way I can imagine
and some I probably can't.
Now, that was 19 books ago.
Aren't you all glad
you're here today?
That was 19 books ago.
If nothing else, because the
Malcolm Gladwell 10,000-hour rule,
I had to have gotten at
least a little better.
Which brings me to the
Sleepwalker, my most recent novel.
The Sleepwalker actually had its
origins when I was having lunch
with the director of the University
of Vermont hospital sleep
center in Burlington.
I was going to write a book about
dreams, that great fright in abyss,
the id, the subconscious.
And, I wanted to understand
the physiology
of the brain when we dream.
And, he had just come from a
patient who was a sleep walker.
And, so rather naturally our
conversation gravitated there.
And, suddenly, he was telling me
stories of people who sleep cook,
sleep drive, sleep jog,
sleep sex, sleep murder.
And, I was absolutely entranced.
I knew that this, this was what I
wanted my next novel to be about.
This was especially interesting
to me because I love the research
that goes into a novel and
sleep study is a very new field.
It was only in 1968 that the
term arousal disorder was coined.
It wasn't until 1979 that modern
medicine began to categorize all
of the different kinds of
parasomnias that exist.
And, forensics sleep medicine,
the investigation of sleep crime,
as a discipline, it
dates back only to 2007.
Moreover, sleep walking
is very common.
10% of children sleep walk.
Nearly 4% of adults do too.
If you have depression or an
obsessive compulsive disorder,
you are three and one half
times more likely to sleep walk.
The University of Vermont
hospital sleep center had six beds
and they are filled almost
every night of the year.
Now, in all fairness, a lot of those
beds are for patients being treated
for sleep apnea, but
you see my point,
sleep walking is very, very common.
Now, here is what sleep
walking is not.
Acting out a dream.
Sleep walking occurs in the
earlier cycles of sleep.
Dreams tend to occur in the latter
rapid eye movement cycles of sleep.
Here's what sleep walking is.
Imagine that the part of your
brain that controls judgment
and motor activity,
the part of your brain
that controls motor activity is wide
awake, and the part of your brain
that controls judgment and
memory is sound asleep.
Virtually, anything you can do
when you are awake you can do
when you are sleep walking.
What triggers sleep walking.
Exhaustion, stress, alcohol, sleep
deprivation, certain medications.
We've all heard stories of the
way certain sleep aids lead
to sleep walking experiences.
And, it may come down to one little
chemical messenger in the brain,
gama aminobutyric acid or GABBA.
It calms the brain and
it helps us to sleep.
And, it develops as we grow up which
is why children are more likely
to sleep walk than adults.
Scientists speculate
that some adults
who sleep walk may simply have
GABBA never fully developed
or that is far more
sensitive to those triggers.
As you can see, I loved
researching this book.
John Gardener, great teacher
of writing short story writing
novelist once said there are two
ways to wake a reader
from the fictional dream.
Clumsiness, bad writing, and
inauthenticity, bad research.
I've been guilty of both.
I certainly know when I have
writers block in the morning
that it means I haven't
done my homework.
I haven't done sufficient research
to really understand the scene
and so I need to roll up my
sleeves and do some more.
But, I also know this.
All of you who give me the
great gift of reading my books,
which is an honor and I
can't thank you you enough,
read my books not necessarily to
learn something though you might.
You might learn something
about sleep walking.
about the Armenian genocide
but you read my books for the same
reason I read the books of so many
of the amazing authors here because
I'm entranced by the characters
and I want to know what's
going to happen to them.
Because there's something in
the story that is causing me
to phonetically turn the pages which
brings me back to sort of the yin
and yang of that John
Gardener quote.
And, it's a quote I
love from Ian Forrester.
We all know that fiction
is truer than history
because it goes beyond the evidence.
I think about that quote
a lot when I am writing.
My goal in life is never to
write the same book twice.
That point noted, I think
my books tend to fall
into two sort of general categories.
Contemporary literature
and historical fiction.
The contemporary literature well,
it's such books as the Double Bind
about Laurel Estabrook, a social
worker in Vermont who works
with the homeless who believes
that she has found among
her clients the bastard son
of J Gadsby in Daisy Fay Buchanan.
Or, Close Your Eyes, Hold Hands.
About Emily Shepherd, a 16 year
old girl trying desperately
to keep it together after a melt
down at Vermont's lone
nuclear plant.
The historical fiction well, it
falls into such realms as the Light
in the Ruins about one
Italian families collaboration
with the Nazis and the
price they will pay even
after the second world war.
Or, the Sandcastle Girls,
a big sweeping epic love
story set in a Aleppo, yes.
That Aleppo that has broken all
of our hearts the last five years
in 1915 in the mist of
the Armenian genocide.
But, all of these books I think
have two threads in common
that you will see woven
into the sleep -- is this.
And, it's an emotion.
It's a sensation.
And, whenever I think of it,
I think of a moment in one
of my absolute favorite
television shows ever, Madman.
You don't have to have
seen a moment of the show
to know this sensation,
but here's the scene.
A middle school aged girl named
Sally Draper gets out of a cab
on New York city's upper east side.
And, instead of going to school as
she is supposed to, she goes home.
And, everyone who's watching this
scene knows that she is going
to catch her father in bed with the
downstairs neighbor and it is going
to be devastating for
dad and daughter.
And, I'm watching the scene
alone in my TV room in Vermont
at five of 11 on a Sunday night.
And, I'm talking to
the television set.
I'm saying no, Sally, no, no.
Get back in the cab.
Go to school.
Don't go home, but she does go home.
She catches her father and
it is indeed cataclysmic.
That emotion, it's dread.
When my books work they
are in part about dread.
Now, I have to digress briefly here.
When I was talking about dread with
a reporter in San Diego in January,
she said something to me that was
really smart and surprised me.
She said it might be
dread for your readers
but it's something else
for your characters.
And, I waited.
And, she had with her a paperback
of my novel the Guest Room
which had just been published.
And, she went to the epigraph.
And, the epigraph is from one
of those door stops I
just love [inaudible].
And, it's this.
I don't think I can love you
so deeply if you had nothing
to lose and nothing to regret.
And, she said it might
be dread for your readers
but the underlying emotion
for your characters is regret.
And, I think she's on to something.
I think of regret a lot when
I think of the sleep walker.
The other thread from my other
books I think you will see
in this new one goes back to
something my daughter said.
My daughter's here today.
She's a young actor,
immensely astute.
She's been reading
my books for years.
She's actually read parts or all
of my last three books on audio.
After she read a rough draft
of Close Your Eyes, Hold Hands,
she said to me dad, take this as
a compliment because I mean it
that way, but I think
your sweet spot
as a writer is seriously
messed up young woman.
And, she's right.
Just think of the woman in
those books that I mentioned.
Laurel Estabrook in the Double
Bind spiraling into madness
after a cataclysmic sexual assault.
Emily Shepherd in Close Your Eyes,
Hold Hands popping Oxycontin tablets
as if they are M and M's.
Sarah [inaudible] in The Light
in the Ruins, a partisan fighting
against the Nazis in the second
world war forever disfigured
in a fire fight.
Now a burner or a cutter
but with flame.
Or, all of those Armenian girls and
the Sandcastle Girls [inaudible].
Forever scarred by what they endured
under the searing Assyrian sun.
You will meet two more of
them in the Sleepwalker.
Vermontor's in this case.
The Sleepwalker set in 2000.
It's the story of Anna Leigh
Ahlberg [assumed spelling],
a 48 year old architect, wife,
mother of two, who one August night
in the year 2000 sleepwalks
into oblivion.
Just disappears.
And, now, in the year 2017,
one of her daughter's
Lianna [assumed spelling],
a mother herself, is chronicling the
way 17 years earlier her mother's
disappearance forever
scarred her family.
I love what the Washington
Post said about this book.
They called it dark, Hitchcockian.
And, Publishers Weekly
call it a stylish fusion
of mystery and domestic thriller.
I love those reviews because
they got at the novel.
There are five players in the drama.
There's Annalee Alhberg,
the sleepwalker.
Her husband, Warren, an English
professor at the nearby college.
They have two daughters.
Lianna, 21 years old in the
year 2000, an aspiring musician
of sorts, and 12 year old Paige.
Paige is an athletic outlier
of sorts and a ski racer.
Now, I mentioned there are
five players in the drama.
Who's the fifth?
Gavin Rikert, 33 years old.
A detective with the Vermont
state police who's leading the
investigation onto
Annalee's disappearance.
And his relationship
with 21 year old Lianna
as the novel progresses
becomes as we want to say
on Facebook, complicated.
Now, before I turn it over to you
for your questions about gosh,
anything, I'm going
to read you one page.
It is the first page of the novel.
And it may or may not
be a diary entry.
It makes all the sense in the world
you awaken and smell smoke and see
that the cat at the foot
of your bed is on fire.
And, so, you scoop him up
and race to the bathroom
and douse him with water in the tub.
You reassure him that he'll be fine.
He is fine, telling him
that everything's okay.
You hold him firmly but
gently under the faucet
because you are worried
about his burns.
The only thing is you're not awake.
But you're not precisely
dreaming either.
After all, in the morning, the
sheets were wet where the cat slept
when you both went back to bed,
and there is fur in the tub.
There are scratch marks on your
arms and the back of your hands
because the cat was justifiably
resistant to the idea of a bath
in the middle of the night.
And, of course, the
animal never was on fire.
Nothing in the house was on fire.
And, you're a reasonable person.
You know that cats don't
spontaneously combust.
But, in the middle of the night,
in the fidelity of that instant,
you were saving the cats life
and that's all that mattered.
Or, another time you open your eyes
in the charcoal dark and decide
that you're hungry so you
stroll to the kitchen and whip
up an omelet tossing
out the whisked eggs
in the [inaudible] little
cheddar cheese and a hand full
of baby aspirin because
in the murkiness
of the moment you were
craving the sweet and sour tang
of orange Saint Joseph's.
Or, you decide to go
for a swim in the river.
Or, you are teased by a stirring
between your legs than a craving
and so you reach for
the body beside you.
And, if no one's there,
you push off the sheets
and you climb from the bed.
You will search out a
stranger who will satisfy it.
With any luck, you will
wake before you find one.
But, not always.
It is you are vampuric.
And, while it would be easy
to use words like insatiable
or inquenchable, they would be
inprecise because the liberty needs
of your sleeping soul
will be stated.
They will and that's the problem.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
And, the first question is the
hardest for you and for me.
Yes. And, I will repeat
the question.
>> So, from the title
[inaudible] book number one,
what's next after Sleepwalker?
>>Chris Bohjalian: The title
of the Sleepwalker says book
number one, what's next.
Book number one suggests
that this is a series.
It's not. What I believe
happened is this.
I was so enamored with
Emily Ahlberg and Lianna
that when I finished the
book I missed them and, so,
I wrote a prequil short
story called The Premonition
about Ana Leigh's life
before she disappeared.
And, you can, you know,
certainly find that at all
of the online bookstores.
And, I think that the creation
of the premonition
created this misperception
that there was going to be a sequel.
I doubt there will ever be --
thank you for bringing that up.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The question is this what
is my response to Moby Dick,
one of the great door stops
of American literature.
I like Moby Dick.
It's not my favorite door stop.
And, it is a door stop like many
door stops that has material
that would never survive
an editor in 2017.
Exhibit A, the amount you learn
about whaling and Moby dick.
Exhibit B the fact that Victor Hugo
spent 60 pages describing the sewer
system of Paris and [inaudible].
And, I find this very interesting
about door stops today
and door stops then.
And, there have been some great
door stops published recently.
I will share with you some
of the my favorite door stops
of the modern era.
But, I find this very interesting.
Most [inaudible] we think of Les
Miserables we think of the musical
or we think of the movie.
And, they begin with Jean
Valjean stealing the candlesticks.
In the novel, Les Miserables, the
candlesticks are stolen on page 105.
You have 105 pages about the
goodness of the cardinal.
That would never happen in 2017.
But, among the door stops, I
have just loved that are modern.
I loved A Little Life.
I loved City on Fire.
I loved the Gold [inaudible].
The door stop is -- I
love the corrections --
the door stop is alive and
well, it's just different.
Yes. Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Please use the mics.
We have two mics up here
so we can all here you.
>>Chris Bohjalian: This is
called the dramatic pause.
>> So what do you think
are some of the keys
to giving a character
authenticity as a writer?
>>Chris Bohjalian: What are the keys
to giving a character authenticity.
Your questions are so terrific.
The key to giving a character
authenticity is minutia.
It's not simply though
-- this is critical.
Her eyebrows, his hairline.
It's the details of
his or her back story.
What do we know about
how he or she grew up.
What were the defining
moments in their childhood.
All of that matters.
And, yes, what do they
do during the day.
What is their professional
life like.
When I was writing before, you
know, kindness, which is in part
about a public defender, I spent
days following a public defender
to understand how she
spent her life.
When I was writing midwives, I must
of interviewed 65 moms and dads
who had their babies at home as
well as midwives and OBGYN's.
So, you know, it's
doing the research.
Now, I will say this.
It is also important to bring your
imagination to that character.
Most of us if we are writers
always have our fingers pressed
against the glass looking at
the party we weren't invited to.
And when you watch, you learn.
>> I think she was first.
>> Thank you.
>>Chris Bohjalian: Hello.
>> Hi. I want to go back to what
you said a minute ago about things
that wouldn't survive editors today.
Do you think that's because we
have shorter attention spans
or we're used to action movie --
I mean, what do you
think the difference is?
>>Chris Bohjalian:
What is the difference.
Why do I believe that the
door stop has changed.
Is it shorter attention.
Yes. Let's begin there.
I think there are at
least two reasons.
We do have shorter
attention spans beginning
with the way the digital
age draws us relentlessly
to the social networks
and to our phones.
That's a reality.
But, I think there's another reality
that is affected our attention spans
for literature and
how we approach it.
And this isn't necessarily
a bad one.
I think the last ten years
have been a renaissance
in television whether
it's Breaking Bad,
The Sopranos, Madmen, The Crown.
There is so much remarkable
television that we watch,
and I think all of us now approach
literature with this understanding
that you can't read a political
thriller today without thinking
of House of Cards, for instance.
I think we got time for
one more or two more.
Two more, okay.
>> I have a question about two of
your historical base novel Skeleton
at the Feast and The
Light in the Ruins.
In both of those you have very
complex characters on both sides
of the issue, many of
whom are Nazi collaborates
and one case sort of
a Nazi partisan.
Do you ever get blow back from
your portrayal of participants
in those novels or the
way you portray the --
>>Chris Bohjalian: Okay,
the question is this.
In Skeleton's of the
Feast, which is a novel
about one German's family complicity
in the Holocaust or the Light
in the Ruin which is about when
Italian families collaboration
with the Nazi's, have
I ever gotten blow back
for having German characters
or Italian collaborators
who have some degree of
moral ambiguity to them,
they are not simply the
devil with a [inaudible].
No, I don't think I have.
And, I think that's largely because
Skeletons at the Feast and the Light
in the Ruins unlike a lot
of my contemporary literature
aren't about moral ambiguity.
They are first and fore most
about people's willingness
to be complicitous with evil.
As Francesca [inaudible] says
Francesca [inaudible] says
in the Light in the Ruins, which
is talking about her father's deal
with the Nazi's, you
are collaborating
with the cowardly angels,
quoting Donte.
>> Thank you.
>>Chris Bohjalian: I think
this is the last question.
>> Yes, hi.
I've read a lot of stuff
you've said and as the person
who introduced you said living
in Vermont I think you said has
really inspired your writing.
And, having living in Burlington for
a long time, I'm just wondering why,
you know, moving from New York
to Vermont really, you
know, inspired you?
>>Chris Bohjalian: Why did
my wife and I move to Vermont
and why did it inspire us.
We moved to Vermont to be completely
honest because it was the 1980's
and we were looking at
ourselves in the mirror
as an advertising executive
and a bond trader
and we were afraid we
were on an up escalator
that if we did not get off now
when we were young we would
forever lock us into that role.
And that wasn't the
role that we wanted.
It wasn't feeding our souls.
My wife is an immensely
talented photographer
and she wasn't taking pictures.
I had no idea if I had any
talent at all as a writer.
Certainly, I hadn't demonstrated it,
but I wanted desperately
to be a writer.
And, so, we made the decision to
get off that financial up escalator,
take a risk and see if
we could keep our soul.
Because here's what I
always tell young writers.
I tell young artists you
have one chance in this world
to live your life the
way it should be.
Live it with an appropriate
moral compass.
Do the right thing
and feed your heart.
Today, I want all of you to
feed your souls with books.
Thank you so much for joining.
I'm so honored.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at llc.gov